well there had been several incidents
two really serious ones that stick in
the mind first from was in 1982 when the
volcano marked Cullen Gong went off and
there was a British Airways flight that
was flying a 36,000 feet and all the
engines stopped and the pilots had a
nightmare of a time but they got down to
about 11,000 feet and they they managed
to restart the engines the second case
was about seven years later over Mount
redoubt in Alaska in that case they were
at about 40,000 feet all four engines
stopped and eventually they managed to
restart and
make a safe landing before the Cullen
Gong incident we all thought it was oh
you just get a bit of a bit of wear on
these blades because it's sandy and
evasive and you might block up some
holes in the turbines that of course is
a long-term deterioration it doesn't
stop the engines the thing that stops
the engines and there was a very long
and careful investigation after both the
events but there was a huge report in
the US Geological Survey which is
interesting that it's the geologists
getting involved as well as the
engineers which shows that the contents
of these volcanic clouds contain a lot
of particles which are rather like glass
and what happens is that these particles
they enter the engine and they get to
the combustion chamber here which is
like a furnace well over a thousand
degrees centigrade the particles get
into the combustor and then this liquid
glass which is a sort of thick syrupy
liquid sprays over the turbines and it
partially blocks
the air passages so that the right
amount of AI can't get can't get through
the engine anymore that's the fan which
sucks air in that's the compressor which
compresses it and it the fuel is
squirted into the combustor where which
of course gets very hot and then the hot
gases expand out to the turbines and the
turbines are there to to drive the
compressor and it's the the nozzle guide
vanes here and the turbine blades that
follow that are covered in the glass I
mean the damage that the compressor is
quite serious but it isn't that which
shut the engine back
yes I went to a talk by the the pilots
of the gum gum event who told a very
moving dramatic story but the first
thing they saw was sort of sparks and a
glow of light in front of the windscreen
and the passengers could see flashes of
light from the wing leading edges and
streaks of flame or orange light coming
out of the both the back and the front
of the engines which was all these
particles glowing the effect was to sort
of sandblast the windscreen so they
couldn't see through it anymore when
they came into land they had great
difficulty and one of the pilots was
standing up and talking to the other
pilot and they were like that there was
just a tiny really clear bit of glass
right at the edge of the windscreen and
they came in basically off from
instruments but for the last bit you do
need to see where some people might
think they're being overly cautious by
grounding all these planes what do you
think about that the Gundam passengers
formed an association and performed the
club and having been on an aeroplane for
I think it was something more than 11
minutes without power and writing notes
to your nearest and dearest and thinking
your end had come now at least two plane
loads of passengers have had that
experience and I don't think anybody
else would like the experience the aero
engine manufacturers do all they can to
to cope with the effects of dust but
there's no way you can cope with coating
your turbine in glass it's just all you
can do is just avoid it and all the
effort since has been keep out of the
clouds